il accuse de lui avoir coupé le dos avec
une bouteille de vodka il l'accuse de
l'avoir trompé avec l homme respecté
dans son lit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a beau dire cette émission connaît sa
marge est toujours mariée ben oui des
heureux ben oui des enfants ben non
parce qu'elle est plus âgée que moi ah
c'est sûr mais
c'est pas le problème annie a déjà une
petite fille oui moi de mon côté frais
contre qu'au report alors faut croire en
un peu vous êtes vous êtes heureux oui
avec elle ça serait bien oui très bien
c'est quoi le quotidien sauf le
quotidien
on se lève on fait l'amour et l'amour
on arrachait beaucoup le petit outil
dans le tiroir à
vis avant leur série mais je n'aurais
pas rouillé mais là c'est comme un
sécateur salue bien tort et ma femme au
6 mai
et aimer et la retraite ça va pas non
mais c'est pour ça mais j'étais sur une
prothèse de hanche alors je suis malade
du diabète dwayne j'ai remplacé jean
reno pour risque pas d'y remettre de
france notoriété c'est pas difficile à
vis de notoriété il n'ya pas des mauvais
côtés aussi parce que je suis une très
malade des nerfs à l'intérieur et il ya
des gens biens sont pas trop bien alors
des fois hebinger je prends leur mal
logés dans moment et j'ai pas besoin de
moi je ne sois pas c'est que je vends
tout dur
[Musique]
c'est le premier baiser entre deux
hommes dans une télé réalité c'était pas
mieux c'est l'avis d'alain fin
et qu'est ce que c'est a eu comme
conséquence pour vous ça à bas des
milliers de menaces de mort mais des
lendemains ses dirigeants c'est une
blague s'est intégralement des lettres
écrites manuscrites au bas c'était sur
les abats ya eu oui les amis de courrier
chez nous et sinon je vais réseau oui
j'aimais sa jouerie commentaires aussi
classiquement ça a été une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a déménagé aussi mais
non ici bas on est on est les seuls
agriculteurs des de l'amour et
d'anciennes jamais avoir donné à notre
adresse vous aviez vous aviez une
pathologie c'est à dire un truc qu'il
voulait tuer à tout moment c'est tout et
c'est toujours mais stabilisé alors cela
s'appelle la maladie de cas d'asile
c'est une maladie on est au moins 2000
en france à l'avoir cédé gérer ce
dégénérescence cérébrale j'ai 100 % de
chances d'en mourir d'espérance de vie
de 62 ans j'en ai bientôt 47 donc tu
vois un petit peu le
mépris
que vous vouliez avoir des enfants ouais
et est-ce que ça du coup ces années
c'est une question parce que si vous
avez si vous arrivez à avoir des enfants
ce qui prend déjà pas mal de temps est
ce que le fait que du coup y ait cette
cette échéance qui est très négative et
de revanche je suis désolé mais est ce
que ça vous fait beau et question parce
que finalement si cet enfant arrive un
père vous allez vous retrouver seul
peut-être pour l'éduquer c'est pas
évident déjà que deux hommes c'est pas
facile à faire rentrer dans l'est dans
l'établé jamais cessé
j avais déjà pensé gym évidemment il a
de beaucoup de réfléchi et lui il se
sent prêt a déjà pour un change tout la
kora et puis on va peut-être passer au
travers puis surtout vous n'êtes pas
morts encore
fait comment peut-elle elle je pose une
question gagner encore quand on sait que
l avais dit qu était d'abord le 2 +
premier jour aller chez lui à
l'enregistrer tout quelle femme fait ça
2 quand elle a eu des coups elle a dit
que les mac et baca maquillage et
petit roi pour se défendre elle a cité
l'intégralité d'un film avec matt damon
qui est en fait une reprise de plein
soleil avec avec alain delon et pour se
défendre un professeur il plaît comment
cette fille peut encore gagner
en fait ce qui est intéressant dans ce
double procès parce qu'on en a déjà eu
deux ans c'est qu'en fait c'est johnny
depp qui a tapé des propos diffamation
est à l'apaisement des journaux l'as et
dans le washington post donc aux etats
unis c'est pour ça que le procès ait
lieu là bas et qu'il est diffusé à la
télévision et ce qui est hyper
intéressant c'est que justement tout et
des balais pour la première fois
notamment l'huile il accuse de lui avoir
coupé le doigt avec une bouteille de
vodka il l'accuse de l'avoir trompé avec
l homme respecté dans son lit ouais
alors ça c'est dans le précédent à
pardonner et ce qui est hyper
intéressant c'est que c'est pas vraiment
une histoire d'argent en fait lui
aujourd'hui ce qu'il veut c'est redorer
son image s'il a perdu un contrat disney
il a perdu son foetus et de la perte du
contrat disney 10 à combien s'élève
parce que je sais que le film s'est
également toutes les franchises qui
retourne souléry ce n'est ces trois dit
stella ses 221 millions de dollars qu'il
a perdu une paille mais ce qu une
occupation c'est comme comme elle sait
qu'elle est en perte de vitesse ne
faisait pas marre et qu'elle sait que
c'est évidemment filmer le code visuel
elle apparaît volontairement des fêtes
masque avec nettement moins de
maquillage alors c'est une jeune femme
qui est constamment à prêter et là il ya
vraiment regardé comme une m'a détruite
regard de la mairie ce qu'on n'est pas
en train d'assister à un petit excès de
mythes ou dans l'autre sens ce qui est
en train de faire du mal à me tout en
maintenant des filles ce serbe nous
sommes également totalement et amber
heard ailleurs l'avait prévenu lui avait
dit tu crois vraiment qu'on va croire
que tu as un mec moi tu es il a
d'ailleurs pu prouver d'une pub montrer
ce message qu'elle eut envoyé mais où
elle a quand même réussi un petit peu à
a écorché as safir craquer le vernis
johnny cette semaine c'est en parlant
d'un de sa fille avec vanessa paradis et
du fait que son papa les initier un peu
à la marijuana qu'il est toléré qu'elle
ait une relation à la même époque où
lily rose croix qu'elle avait 14 ans
elle fréquente à un homme lit énormément
plus âgé qu'elle et à qui l'autorisait
de passer la nuit donc là j'avoue que
sur sur la drogue aux états unis ça
rigole pas et là je pense qu'il s'est
pris une petite équipe
est-ce que tu au courant rené charles
qui le sait ça c'est rené charles vu
reprendre le rôle de son père pour
protéger préserver sa mère dont il veut
devenir ben non rené char lan na de
charles c'est rené et c'est le trône et
le manager on sait que c'est la musique
un peu de rap tout ça mais maintenant il
veut reprendre tout ça en main parce que
c'est bien rendu compte que tous les
ménages heures avant sa la pa talent
marché est-ce que ça va se faire il aura
peut-être pas marché non pas tellement
alors moi je pense que ça va se faire
est ce que tu disais tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs été très juste par rapport au
choix qu'a fait céline depuis la 10
réaction de rené lui connaît la musique
qui connaît la musique jeune et cette
semaine chez nous on adagio qui s'est
exprimé dans en aparté sur canal qu a
expliqué qu'il avait tout fait pour
faire un duo avec céline qu'il avait
essayé de la comptable à multiples
reprises elle a refusé je prends cet
exemple là juste pour dire que son fils
à mon avis mais le bon personnage pour
l'amener à faire des duos nouveau qui
pourrait relancer sa carrière et elle à
autre chose elle aurait tué les ponts
avec la famille de rené ouais c'est le
gendre de rené char ou un directeur de
la star ac' d'ailleurs aucune arme après
oui s'appelle marc dupré qui a confié
qu'il n'avait plus du tout aucune
nouvelle qui n'avait plus aucune
nouvelle de céline et qui trouvait ça
très triste mais qui pensaient que le
jour où elle se sentira vraiment bien
elle remontera sur scène elle le fera
jamais à moitié pour chanter à moitié
etc